hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the very useful remedies that
Seneca elaborates for us in book three
of his on anger is not something
punctual that we do when we're about to
get angry or we're already starting down
the path and we want to catch ourselves
rather it's something that He suggests
should be a daily or rather nightly
routine for us something that we want to
make into a habit a routine a approach
that we adopt over and over and over
again and it's not something as simple
as it might first seem there's actually
quite a few let's say components or
Dimensions to it so he tells us and this
is in chapter 36 the Mind must be called
to account every day and that's a little
bit of an abbreviation
in the translation the Latin says which
means every day right
and what he's talking about there is
animus which is the mind and it's not
anima the soul but rather the part of us
that does our thinking now remember that
for the stoics this rational part is
also the part that is subject to the
emotion so volcanus s it needs to be uh
called
rightandam so reason is both part of
what's being looked at the rational part
the mind but it's also the tool the
scrutinizer the agent that is looking at
the mind and it's interesting too
because Seneca doesn't say use your mind
to look at your actions or something
like that this is the Mind
scrutinizing itself using its powers of
memory to bring itself to to account and
bringing itself to account is going to
mean judging itself right so this is
really kind of like if we're going to
make an analogy to a whole body exercise
this is the whole mind exercise it
involves memory it involves judgment it
involves a kind of you know meta
cognition that the term people love to
use these days now Seneca says I didn't
come up with this myself this is
actually the practice or more literally
what this person this philosopher who we
actually don't know that much about a
local Roman philosopher sexiest who had
his own minor school this is what he did
this is his practice this is what he
engaged in
and he tells us that when the day was
spent and he had retired to his night's
rest he asked his mind he asked himself
a set of questions which of your ills
your Mala the bad things right that are
hurting you that are screwing you up did
you heal today did you work on which
Vice vitia which uh you know Vice is did
you resist vices that are still in you
and in what aspect have you become
better how have you improved so it's
asking not just about well what
individual things did you do and those
are in the naughty list and these are in
the nice list it's actually asking more
Global questions what are you doing
that's making you better what are you
doing to resist or pair away the bad add
parts of yourself of your mind right
and so Seneca tells us something very
interesting about anger he says your
anger will cease to sin it in in Latin
and lessen mod
so it'll become if not going away
entirely it will become at least more
manageable more tractable it won't be
quite as great it won't break out quite
as easily when brought before a judge
right so who is this judge well it's
yourself it's your own anger it's your
own mind you're using your mind to judge
your mind and now notice one other key
phrase in there when it knows that every
day is going to be brought before the
judge so if you're not making this a
regular practice but only doing it
occasionally you're not providing that
part of yourself that does get angry the
let's call call it warning or sanction
that it needs of getting brought before
the judge and we could ask ourselves
Seneca doesn't go into this
why would anger be deterred in that way
because the part of yourself that gets
angry this is an assumption here doesn't
like being judged doesn't like being
told it got things wrong doesn't like
being told it was
out of bounds or over the line or pick
whatever else you want right
and so anger is going to lessen or cease
and then he says is there anything finer
more literally more beautiful right than
what than this habit
and here habit is a translation of uh
consuetido which you know means custom
also so this is something that you turn
into your own internal Norm governing
yourself a habit that you make for
yourself is anything finer than this
habit of scrutinizing
exiendi right of engaging in a process
of if we want to be more literal about
this
sifting
This this term comes to have a meaning
of examining or scrutinizing but it
actually means like separating out
so that you can find what's good and
what's bad a very interesting metaphor
there so he goes in and he says is
anything finer than this habit what sort
of sleep follows this how peaceful how
deep and how free when now what is this
tells us what this process is like when
the mind has either been praised or
admonished blamed criticized right when
you are telling yourself you did a good
job here so it's not just about tearing
yourself down or saying oh so bad or
anything like that you're you're
criticizing yourself you'll always have
something something to criticize but
you're also praising yourself when you
got something right and he talks about
uh The Sentinel and secret sensor of the
self-conducting its inquiry into one's
character so the Sentinel Speculator or
the one who's looking at not just being
a guard but looking into
it the self sends
and the sensor the sensor isn't just
somebody who says no no you can't print
that it's somebody who looks into
morals or habits or character and then
renders judgments and sanctions so you
are being your own sensor and I should
mention here that where the translation
says character in the singular it's
actually moribos which is a term which
is similar to uh constitute constituto
right or habitus these are habits these
are ways of doing things Amores is a
most actually is a custom a habit a a
way in which you typically behave so
your character is formed of all of these
little habits right that come together
in some sort of Nexus so that is what
you're doing you're scrutinizing that
and Seneca says hey this is what I do
every day let me tell you about it and
this is how he closes he says
I exercise this jurisdiction this power
potestate daily and plead my case before
myself
I speak my case to myself I tell myself
about my case and then I of course look
at it without bsing myself he says when
the light has been removed and my wife
has fallen silent aware of this habit
that's now mine I examined my entire day
and go back over what I've done and said
and this is a very important part hiding
nothing from myself so not not going uh
well I don't want to look at that part
over there right because it's going to
make me feel bad he also says passing
Nothing by not making any excuses and
then he says how can I do this
well I don't have to fear any
consequence why because
I also can tell myself
see that you don't do it again and
now I forgive you now forgive
that might be a little bit too strong of
a term the Latin is actually TB ignosco
I literally Overlook or am ignorant of
what you did wrong you know you you let
it go you could say so I mean forgive
Works
um Let Go pass over those all work as
well and so if you're brutally honest
with yourself
then you can actually turn this into a
process of self-improvement and he gives
examples of the sort of things that he
says to himself which I think maybe a
lot of us could say he says in that
discussion you spoke too aggressively
now notice this he doesn't just say in
that discussion you spoke to
aggressively all right that was bad I
forgive you let it go try to do better
instead he's teaching and learning
himself he says from now on don't get
involved with people who don't know what
they're talking about so it's not just
looking back over it and acknowledging
criticizing and then leaving it there's
also a this is how you're going to do
better next time
uh people who've never learned don't
want to learn you admonish that fellow
more candidly than you should as a
result you didn't correct him you
offended him in the future consider not
just whether what you say is true but
whether the person you're talking to can
take the truth a good person Delights in
being admonished all the worst people
have the hardest time putting up with
correction right and so you know it goes
on and there's other examples but what's
really nice about this is it illustrates
that it's not just about putting
together a list of what you did and
remembering all the things and maybe
feeling some negative emotions feeling
some shame feeling some anxiety or
something like that and then forgiving
yourself there's also a cognitive
process of which is also something that
can become a habit of looking at the
situation and saying all right what do I
need to do next time
what do I need to have in mind next time
so that I can do better and if we do
this then you know not just with anger
but what all sorts of other problems
that we are experiencing Our lives our
habits our Behavior our mindset will
gradually get better and better and
better